warning this video has been heavily
censored due to YouTube removing the
original upload please please check the
links to the uncensored version in the
description below for the full effects
for the rest of you who are either
sneaking at work or watching this with
your mum in the living room here you go
if any of you have been following anime
for any decent period of time you'd know
that to staple in the whole medium
itself in all its sexualized fighting
harem inducing and cutesy mo glory is
the idea of fanservice now for any of
you who are new to anime might not be so
familiar with anime concepts and the
otaku lingo allow me to fill you in
fanservice is a term derived from the
anime and manga fandom itself to
describe material that is intentionally
added to a series or show was the
purpose of catering towards a certain
group of people all fans have given them
exactly what they want the definition of
the term self is actually quite vague
since basically anything can technically
be defined as fanservice
which could range from anything to a
shot of the characters panties making
the art style emphasize cute ditzy girls
or even the inclusion of a little sister
character because in the end it all
boils down to a concept of well
servicing the fans
nowadays though fanservice is normally a
phrase used by anime fans myself
included to describe the gratuitous the
patient or female characters in a
sexualized manner which normally equates
to the unnecessary exposure of female
body parts by means of dodgy camera
angles randomly inserted sexualized
scenes or revealing clothing that is
only worn for the purpose of emphasizing
every possible assets or to put it in
guy language [__] titties [__] ass
and [__] girls man it's a topic that
surely anyone watching anime has
probably noticed and as one of the many
reviewers that have complained about
fanservice getting in the way of the
quality of the show it does beg the
question what is the point of fanservice
well the answer to that question is so
simple and obvious that I'm sure 90% of
the people watching this video would be
able to answer it sex sells
I said it years ago in my harem video
and I'll say it again now it doesn't
matter if it's in the film in the street
gaming music or even selling [__]
burgers sex makes money and that's just
a universal fact especially if it's
aimed towards guys most of the time we
cannot help it we are subconsciously
drawn to the stuff as I'm sure many of
the people who clicked on a video just
for the thumbnail are about to comment
on and we can only blame our hormones
for that so having said all of this of
course is obvious why most anime have
servicing them so what's the problem you
may ask it's something I often let's
complain about in my own reviews to
which a common reply I get is why you go
complaining about tips again does he not
like girls or something well of course I
like girls you dunce but you know what
else I like being so immersed in the
story that I forgets about everything
else and just become completely
engrossed in the world at the anime is
presenting to me I watch anime to enjoy
the story the action or just as a form
of escapism and it's kind of distracting
if they're trying to make me horny at
the same time or are you gonna have me
believe that there are people who can
stay totally engaged in a serious story
while simultaneously wanting to have a
wank
shut up Shinji there's only so much
fanservice someone can take before
accidents there emerging in the story
the more obviously placed the fanservice
the more likely is to break immersion
which is my biggest problem with
fanservice
unless that's the entire point of the
show aka the edgy Jon rrah I have no
problems but yet she Jonah as a whole
since you go into the show expecting
this stuff my big problem is that not
only I was seeing this more and more in
modern day anime but it's also getting
progressively more extreme the matter
what genre show is in and the thing is
that it's become so predominant in anime
in this day and age that we as hardcore
fans don't really notice it anymore or
at least it seems like we've just
accepted things as the way they are to
make my point let's rewind back a decade
ago to have a little look at an anime
called Love Hina
machina is a harem comedy that came out
in the early 2000s whose plot involves a
university dropout finding himself
living with a bunch of beautiful girls
it was a completely tasteless and
average show even if it was one of my
guilty pleasures but my point is that
most of the comedy derives from the main
character stumbling into a group of
half-naked girls or accidentally finding
himself in sexual situations for one
reason or another so you'd think that
such an anime would be riddled with
every kind of fanservice there is and
for its time it kind of was you had you
use your panty shots and tip flashes in
every episode but looking back in
comparison to today's standards
everything seems kind of tame even
looking at stimulus shows on its time
such as mega mur or van dread you'd see
that everything seems a lot more toned
down more subtle and less explosive
fast-forward to the modern day and now
we have over glorified crotch shots Dane
likes tentacle rape bullet dodging
breasts and anti bomb boobs in one piece
you can visibly see how breast size have
gradually grown in the course of a
decade and heck in 2012 alone we've
introduced toothbrush sex spit fetishes
and hot zombies to the huge list of
where - [__] that we just look over
because we've just accepted it as a part
of the craziness of anime but looking
back you have to ask yourself when it's
all this starts to happen in my time of
watching anime it wasn't always like
this and from what I can remember it was
somewhere between the 2007 2008 periods
when I started to notice the transition
the mainstream release of the perverse
flight gasm that was Iquitos in' the
glorified sexual ization of yoko from
gurren lagaan
and the sudden amplification of karin
are shots from Code Geass r1 to r2 don't
get me wrong the idea of fanservice is
not a new concept at all has existed for
as long as most people can remember
going back to the 80s you had Fujiko
from the loop on the third series who
was the poster child of fanservice for
that era but never before has it been so
predominant and oh so obvious as it is
now has anime become so reliant on
fanservice that companies have no
confidence that a compelling story and
interesting characters is all you need
to make an anime cell and worst of all
have we the fanbase glorified this the
basement over which bleach character has
the biggest breast size all going over
our waifu
creating thousands of new memes after
the latest incest fetish that spread
like wildfire I'm looking at you for
Chan it just seems that fanservice has
not only become the normality in anime
but it is progressively getting more and
more extreme as time goes on as if
animation
are constantly trying to one-up each
other in a contest to shock the viewer
and you talk of community has just
evolved to accept any kind of toned up
fanservice for just the way things are
right now so where does it stop is
aligned ever gonna be drawn or other
handful of shows without fanservice
going to become even rarer I only say
this because I love anime as a medium of
storytelling and entertainment I want to
get more people into anime and spread
the love but how can I defend the
dignity of a medium against the childish
and pornographic preconceptions the
general populace seemed to have a bit
when it looks like the medium doesn't
even have any dignity in itself while it
can be argued that fanservice doesn't
actually add anything to the quality of
a story or characters I would be lying
if I said I wanted it to disappear
completely there are still great shows
that have fanservice in them and no
matter what us guys say we will always
be subconsciously drawn to the TNA and I
know you girls secretly love your man
service as well all I can ask is that
the Craters try to just tone it down a
little and have a bit more dignity in
their own series cause as with
everything else it needs some moderation
the way things are going though this
current trend of fanservice doesn't look
like it's slowing down at all perhaps
one day fans may get tired of it and
demand something else or perhaps a diet
already been cast past the point of no
return
so we should just all get used to where
and move on so I'm asking you guys now
do you think there's too much fast
service in anime nowadays leave a
comment or video response free chance to
get featured in my next ranks anyway
that's it for me now though so if you
want to know where my promise part two
of the big three rant is gone
just look in the description but in
response to my last rant what do you
think of the big three and his fans
whether it be the fans praising it as
the anime Segre enough to have descended
from the heavens or the haters
condemning it for quote ruining the
entire anime community there's always
some sort of overreaction and argument
going on
[Music]
[Applause]